all right on kihon was a
and we're just talking about kihon Wasa
um
it's like a shape
and you want to
replicate the shape
from there you work with your teacher to
understand the shape
use the shape
Etc so let's just start with the shape
first thing is
going to be hand shaped
the hand is going to
have a cup
aspect to your palm
but that is not made by
squeezing your bones in like this
what you don't want on the Other Extreme
however is the bones of the hand uh
extending
like this this is not correct okay
um
you have this cup shape to it
but not made by you'll see some people
doing this stuff okay
or you'll see some people in extension
doing that other mistake okay
again this is the kihon was a shape and
as kihonawasa is to be transcended
ultimately the shape is not important
but whenever you're training in
kihonawaza you should do the shape and
if you don't have the shape yet you
should learn the shape so there's a cup
aspect to the palm
then your fingers are
long but not tense
if you tense your fingers you're going
to tend to make that first mistake
you'll sympathetically tense the bones
in your hand okay
okay so my fingers are long
and I'll give little points as we go
along here
in the beginning
uh you want to have that cup in your
palm
in alignment
with your forearm bones to your elbow
so you don't want it here
this way
and then pay attention to this middle
finger
this finger here
and I would actually say a point here
between the middle and the ring
are
connected to that Palm
okay again don't
flex your fingers but keep them long
and as you get this hand shape
keep your forearm
relax
not it's not made by a tension in your
in your arms your forearm is very
relaxed okay
shape of the head
the next shape
is the arm
and I'll give you a reference point here
there's only two R movements they're
really one movement so it's playing with
that uh duality
in place of a Unity you're you're
working through yin and yang back to the
Dao so there's two but ultimately
there's one okay
uh one we'll call the inward the inward
spiral
and the other one is the outward spiral
okay
so I take that hand shape
and my hand goes this way and of course
it can do the reverse
this is we'll call the inward spiral
the hour spiral is just an extension of
its reverse
and then an inversion of it
in
out
I'll give you reference points it's your
elbow
it is not made
by
your shoulder ball and socket joint
working
nor made by your hinging elbow
both of those are incorrect and you'll
tend to do those when the beginner as
you're muscling
you'll use your ball and socket joint
and it'll be uh indicative of that will
be your elbow will come outside of your
shoulder line
so we'll call your shoulder line your
outer rim your elbow will come outside
of your outer rim
marshallally you'll find that to be very
ineffective it'll open you up to a lot
of things and you'll lose a lot of
mechanical advantage
you'll probably injure your shoulders
over the Decades of training
if you're seeking Leverage
you don't want to seek in the art deals
use the elbow hinge a lot you'll see
people use that elbow hinge a lot
so as marker
will say I got
a line at my shoulder
a line halfway at my chest a middle line
another line halfway to my chest and
then another shoulder line
how about my elbow
starts on that shoulder line and when I
do the inward spiral it will come all
the way to that middle line
and that is where uh you'll you're going
to see that it'll have its yin and yang
phases so as it's moving from the
shoulder it's in its uh Yong phase as
the elbow hits my mid PEC here is
starting to go in its Yin phase and at
the completion of the center line it is
done it can't go anymore
so the same thing inward boom making
these incorrect making these incorrect
a way of thinking of it is uh it's
really your elbow you want to be mindful
of not your hand the hand does what it
does
the forearm is relaxed as it is but it
is the elbow that's actually tracing
that pattern
um
for the outward
uh the outward elbow or the outer spiral
uh it's going to cross over okay so down
it'll reach that midpoint and then come
back to the shoulder line okay not not
way out here
back to the shoulder one
a pattern you can keep in mind is that
they make hearts they make a heart
so if you look at our Crest in the back
of the crest you have a universal
pattern and in the middle of the
universal pattern is a heart shape so
you can kind of use that as long as you
remember that it's not the hand tracing
it it's the elbow tracing it the elbow
is tracing
so take the hand shape and the arm shape
and in kihon was a there's never going
to be
uh one side of your body that is making
the shapes and the other one's not okay
so for example uh I wouldn't have this
arm ever hanging or this arm hanging so
this one's in the shape and this arm is
doing nothing it's very relaxed comes
around and then does this I keep the
shapes at all times keep the shapes at
all times so bodies in the shape
and move around in Gigi's not yet well
they're still in the shape
and they're gonna make
uh the two shapes together
as opposed to
something here dead over here
boom
they're making the shapes together
one
you'll see the inward spiral and the
outward spiral on this hand
from
again
boom
for the camera
starting to go
so this hand is starting outward this
hand is technically starting Inward and
it's because it's yin yang but then they
switch so inward goes to outward outward
goes to inward
go here
this way
boom
and then from the back
it's doing that boom
boom
[Music]
again from the back
boom
all right so a good drill on working on
those hand shapes and arm patterns is
the following so I call this a micro
drill so your Keyhole Wasa are drills
and we're going to take the hand shape
and the arm shapes and the sense that
both sides are working
and make a micro drill just out of those
things okay so you have uh katate and
you do the inner spiral
and the outward spiral
inward spiral
no
and Rec spiral
and I'll once I can get the shape
I want to check for the shape so my
hands stay the same even though I'm not
using this hand
keep that side of my body active you can
do an inward spiral here on the strike
as you do the hours
so uh arms are moving
foreign
to my elbow on that that grid that I put
on my torso so I don't want it to go out
push please I don't want it to go out
stays on that shoulder line comes all
the way over the elbow comes all the way
over boom goes all the way over all the
way
thank you
at first
at first you're going to flex everything
uh that is fine
just remember
that as you progress
you should not be using any effort to
accomplish the same means
okay uh so at first
you're going to think it's biomechanical
and skeletal alignment which is fine but
always task yourself with no it's not
okay
uh so uh as we're here in this this
thing again
the egoic minds see skeletal alignment
do you see and uh they're like well yeah
she can't she can't push you or you're
making her energy come up uh so she
can't get a line on you
um if she really tried she she'd push
you over but no the energy goes back
into her okay and you could do whatever
she could stand up
and she could push so here you can't say
I'm underneath it okay and it doesn't
matter that's not what's happening okay
and likewise
as I do the pattern
let me just make this shade okay so for
example
uh you can change where she's at nope
uh
everyone might understand that she can't
push so well that way biomechanically
but if she stands up
and she's pushing on the elbow again
nothing happens but at the same time she
can't she can't push on the hand she
can't push on the hand that way either
you see normally you would think that
would collapse or you would think the
elbow would push down or something or as
she comes from this angle on the elbow
she can't push the elbow that way either
okay
and you can see that I'm still relaxed
but at the beginning it's fine
over tense what I would say
and uh
but continually
trust and gain faith in taking tension
while keeping the shapes that's your
goal get the shape and then keep the
shape as you take away more and more uh
mechanical thinking and more and more
muscle tension
so it looks like these shapes you're
going to need more shapes
to do your Aikido
so you're like where's my where's my up
and down uh robot arms yeah it's not in
the art don't it's not in the keyhole
don't do it in the keyhole okay uh
where's my my inward outward Perry wax
sound wax off it's not in the art okay
so with these with these two spirals
with this heart-shaped spiral
um
in combination with your uh Ashi sabaki
and your Thai sabaki you generate
whatever you wanted to do with the elbow
band or whatever you wanted to do with
the robot arms or the wax all wax off
okay
um so keep that in mind that I have to I
can only do these shapes I can only do
these two Spirals and then I have to
make up whatever I want with how I move
my body and how I move my feet okay
all right shape
there is a shape to the waza and it too
is going to be the spiral in nature uh
and when we say spiral you don't want to
think two-dimensional uh nothing is
two-dimensional in kihonawaza so
um
it's not a x y grid but it's also not a
two-dimensional spiral okay so for
example uh the technique is here it's
not a matter of me getting out of the
way we're now looking at six o'clock and
then uh accelerating then to six o'clock
and they they roll
this is not the shape of the technique
uh you will not have the angle of
cancellations that you want and you're
also not repeating the shape which is
necessary for deeper understandings of
the art so the art is spiral in nature
and something to look for then is uh one
an angle cancellation so let's define
that let's say she just has a fighting
stance okay
and an angle cancellation is a diagonal
line that is traversing the three planes
of height width and depth okay so for
example if I go this way straight across
it's not it's it's an angle cancellation
but not as she comes around 360 with the
elbow or what have you
um also straight down doesn't stop her
from punching me in the face okay
instead it's going to go diagonally in
and down
and this will create
um mechanical checks
just simply put here on all weapons in
the three zones of height width and
depth so uh she tries to kick
or she tries to punch
and that in in uh in effect will create
a field of operation we'll call it a
Zona Sanctuary okay
in the technique jujinage that's what we
called it uh I don't care what you call
it
in jujinage uh your hand is going to do
remember this hand is ultimately going
to do the out the hour spiral this way
so that means it has to begin first
inward
and you can see that you're creating a
place that you can be and operate from
in that chest
okay so I get my body going
starting the movements
oh
and I move into that spot
but I don't now accelerate her that way
this whole thing is going to come around
her whole body
and she'll go that way
so just looking at the shape of the
technique again
get your angle cancellation move into
your Zona sanctuary and then she's going
to go that way
[Music]
much different
from here
and that does not matter
whether you're doing a eb-10 cons such
as I just did so Ed me 10 column
oh whether you're doing Bushido 10 pond
so I'm going this way I still don't want
it over just straight
so you'll see ushero tank on there's
that spot
[Music]
so look for those two things or those
three things an angled cancellation
which is a diagonal cutting through
height width and depth
the established zone is sanctuary that's
where you move that's your axis of
rotation that gives you the final thing
to look for which is we're actually
making a big spiral okay we're not using
an XY grid
all right the shape
of my footwork let me keyhon
we'll do we'll do the ishido 10 con one
that that you did
this okay
so all the other stuff hand shape
symmetry uh spiraling shape
angle cancellation zone of sanctuary
move into it
you can if you want I think you were
doing the one where you stepped so you
brought her around now you're in it
there's the zoning sanctuary and then
you entered okay
so footwork foot shaped
okay we'll scoot back to that
so one
there's the Zona Sanctuary this is where
I do my rotation okay and not gonna
throw her that way she's gonna go around
me okay
so if we remember her body is coming
around right here
you'll see a triangle
this is your uh opening your tsuki for
edini you need a Yin space that you can
enter in
okay this is where I enter you over here
please okay
uh sorry
what I don't want to do is accelerate
her elbow
if not accelerating her elbow
I'm going to
move into the edema space and she's
about to go around like use me for
balance okay
and she's about to go around this is all
light in here this is where I step and I
put my body here
by doing the issue to 10 conversion
boom this is where my body goes
so the reference point is an X
she's gonna make a curve I am rotating
the shape is spiraling but in there is
an edema
and the reference point is going to be
like an X shape so as she's coming
around I go this way but she goes out
this is different from uh a parallel
shape
we're parallel to each other
whoa am I going this way
so think x pattern
when you do the x pattern
the next shape I would like you to keep
is that your back foot
does not float
because you're rotating with her and
you're going to lose your throwing
geometry
and again that doesn't change whether
you'll hear like this
so my back foot is going to remain still
back foot remains still boom
I'm never I'm not accelerating them so I
don't need a little extra
um
inertia forward
so on this one I come this way you have
a lot of having to put weight on that
front foot it unweights the back foot
and it starts to float on you
I'm not doing that I'm going to make a
triangle in the middle of her Circle and
that creates a topsy-turvy effect in her
body
one
two
so two things on the foot shape or the
legwork
the footwork there's an x pattern to
your throat
she goes on the circle edimi goes across
the circle
and then secondly your back foot does
not float okay
we'll do this
all right so again these are
intro shapes you need you want these
shapes you need to make problems of
these shapes keep those shapes and not
worry about what you do with them later
um
what you do with them
is ultimately what all those podcasts
are talking about okay these are the
shapes
uh that generate
the energy
stimulations or requirements necessary
for accessing the god mind
you're going to also do things with
these as you progress mechanically in
your kihon waza so for example uh
tasking yourself with the back foot
being grounded is going to require you
to shift your weight in a much different
way than you would if you can float your
back foot
but with your back foot grounded then
and only then can you start to gain
access to the internal aspects uh where
you're more coke you projecting them
than you are accelerating them there's
no acceleration in Aikido nagawaza
you're going to project that Center uh
against a tactical architecture that is
deconstructing their base of support
which means uh that foot needs to be
grounded and I'm actually in edema going
to attack the planted leg
and for me that's not a beginner uh
application of kihon waza so that's why
it's not in this video but if you look
on our YouTube channel you'll see lots
of techniques where we always attack the
leg
and you truly then are doing a
triangular displacement that's truly
edimi
[Music]
um
but you don't you don't want that in the
very beginning also be careful when you
do that version with your partners who
has learned how to roll roll
for acceleration throws once you
actually deconstruct their base of
support and project their Center out of
it they're finally being thrown they're
not uh
taking a role and so they don't know how
to be thrown and they don't know how to
land from having been thrown and they'll
likely get hurt and they will almost
definitely think that you are an
okay but
the shapes that I gave you today are
something you're going to use all the
time the hand shape the Inward and
outward spiral the Grid on understanding
that spiral from the point of view of
the elbow
and also uh the footwork on how to do it
the angle of cancellation the spiraling
geometry the triangle cutting through
the center of the Spiral the zone of
sanctuary
etc those things are going to be in
every single quixon Wasa and don't
forget the little side note
as you're working these shapes
what you want to do is more and more and
more release release release especially
muscle tension even if it is uh
euphemistically referred to as extension
extension is not correct that's you're
still in tension and intention is also
not correct uh this is not an imaginary
thing okay so you you don't want to use
your mind to imagine these things use
the reference points that I gave you on
your body and the concepts that I gave
you you cannot imagine or intend your
way to these shapes